now i want to see if you can do a little
more of this unpacking of what the
negation looks like
what the converse looks like and what
the contrapositive looks like
for these other guys over here have you
already filled in
a squared plus b squared equals c
squared what do we usually associate
that with
we usually associate that with right
angle triangles okay uh c being your
hypotenuse right
now what this is saying is if you have a
right angle triangle
then this relationship between the sides
of the right angle triangle
must hold right sum of the squares of
the two shorter sides
is the square of the longest side the
hypotenuse okay now i want you and mrs
lee is going to come
around and have a look at what you've
got i want you to come up with what's
the negation
what's the converse and what's the
contrapositive for pythagoras theorem
okay can you do that and then lastly
over here oh sorry
i forgot to ask something is
pythagoras's theorem true humor me
yes it is but importantly this guy along
the end
i put there just to give you a bit of a
uh a foil right
if n is and again i'm still thinking
about whole numbers here if n is an odd
number
is it true that n squared will be
even now clearly not right because you
can think about the squares of the odd
numbers
uh they are 1 9 25
49 and so on none of those n squareds
are even right this is a false statement
obviously
this is false but whether it's true or
false as you saw when we did the first
example
it has implications for the negation it
has implications for the contrapositive
and so on so here's what you're doing
now for the next
five to seven minutes i'd like you to
fill in what is the negation converse
contrapositive translate it for these
particular examples
and then tell me whether they're true or
false
have a go if you've got some questions
or you think you're finished call
mrs lisa right over off you go so guys i
send some most of you are pretty much
there i just want to show you my
here's one i prepared earlier by the way
fun fact um
often the way i prepare to teach you
guys
is i think about well how would i
explain this to the version of myself a
week ago that didn't
know that this was you know made sense
and was true and so often what i'm doing
is
i'm creating notes now these are the
notes i created before i created that
table that you've got there which is why
the the actual table itself is all janky
and handwritten so anyway this is the
one i had that was ready now
just having a look at with with me and
uh i just want to sort of tie this up in
a neat bow and raise an important point
of um
discussion okay so number one when you
have a look at all of the statements
the implications up the top right i very
purposefully wanted to give you
examples that were true like if n is
prime the square root of n definitely is
irrational
pythagoras theorem you've known it for
years but i wanted to give you
false statements because you have to
interact with false statements
a lot when you are proving things and in
particular
sometimes to prove something directly is
very awkward and difficult
but proving that the opposite is false
is much easier let me say that one more
time sometimes proving an implication
true is hard it's a pain it looks long
and awkward
but if you can take the opposite of it
and prove it false
it's great it just like falls out very
nicely right now what that means is
you're trying
the goal is to prove that something is
false which is weird we're not used to
that right
so that's why i wanted to show you one
from the outset you can see
an implication being true means its
negation must be false
and then if you compare the top and
bottom all the way through if an
implication is
true then it's contrapositive is also
true
and if it's false the contrapositive is
also false
now the last reason and actually the
reason why i picked out these particular
examples for your first two columns is
i want you to have a look at my
converses okay
now the converse for the first one we
saw was false it's not always true and
jiao gave us a great counter example
6. we'll do it for you right eight will
do it for you in fact a whole bunch of
even numbers will do it for you okay but
sometimes the converse is true in fact
one of the first things you learned to
do
with pythagoras theorem was if there's
some triangle
you know it's length but you don't know
if it's right angled you can
prove that it's right angled if the
sides form a pythagorean triad okay
so converses can be true but they aren't
always so great care needs to be taken
so we thought that particular one was
false because
a b c just by putting them into an
equation means that they get invaded
as well oh sure okay so you're picking
up on the fact that
i've been very bare in my writing here
when i say a b and c
i refer to them as the shorter two and
the longer side
of a right angle triangle so while it
may be true that abstractly saying
a squared plus b squared equals c
squared means there's some magic
right a good triangle here right what i
meant was is if you have three sides in
a triangle
and you find this relationship to be
true then you can know
that it'll be right angled so the
converse of pythagoras theorem
is true is what i'm trying to say i'll
give you one last fun one just for you
to have a think about
on your piece of paper or your book
wherever you got there can you draw for
me please
three parallel lines
just make sure they're not um i suppose
you could draw them equidistant but it'd
be boring
so just draw three parallel lines like
so
now
once you've drawn three parallel lines
and they really can't be anywhere it'd
be nice if they're different to the
person next to you because then we can
prove that this is generally true
i would like you to put a pair of lines
that cut across
your parallel lines like so and we call
these
transversals translate cut across right
now you can go ahead and actually do
this i'm kind of free handing this so i
can't do it
where i've got this but you can actually
do some measurements and what you can
actually do is just look up for a second
you can measure what we call the
intercepts on these transversals the
intercepts are the
kind of intervals in between the
parallel lines so for example this one
here
actually i'll color them for you so you
can see it this is an intercept
here and then here let me pick a
different color
here is another intercept over here you
can measure them you can get a ruler out
and you can go ahead and just say well i
wonder how long that is i wonder how
long that is
and i'll give you one more just over
here now if you do
this so and if you drew your parallel
lines accurately
you might notice an interesting
relationship
for instance just to make it easier for
you to work out what it is i'll give you
some numbers for free that i'm just
going to make up
if this happened to be one centimeter
and this happened to be two
just by chance it was double okay if you
went over and measured the other
intercepts and you see how that one's
off
on a bit of an angle right so it's going
to be longer right if you found this to
be 1.5
centimeters i can guarantee without
measuring that this last one over here
will be
3. now this is
a geometric property which you may have
encountered in stage
five but it's uh it's seldom actually
used not much
sort of you know rides on this so people
once they learn it if they did they
rapidly forget about it okay but you can
write an if-then
statement out of this geometric property
and i would ask you to
go and prove it for yourself that you'll
see the same kind of ratio business
happening
okay but when you think about
once you've got an if-then statement for
it when you think about the negation the
converse and the contra positive
you'll notice something really
interesting